A kind of Epigenetics that interests psychologists involves modifying DNA
without changing the sequence. Molecular tags known as Methyl Groups get
attached to the DNA and once tagged this can signal for a gene to be turned
off. Or silenced regardless of the actual sequence.
>> So this is an example in mice that was done a while back and it demonstrates
the power of the environment on your genes. Two genetically identical strings
of mice from different mothers turned out looking very different because their
respective mothers had very different diets. Now one pregnant mother was fed a
diet rich in nutrients for things like methyl groups. The other mother was fed
a diet lacking nutrients for these methyl groups. The mother who had a diet
rich in nutrients for methyl groups gave rise to offspring that were obese and
had yellow fur. Whereas the mother that had a diet lacking these nutrients had
normal offspring that were non obese with brown fur. Now the amazing thing
about both of these mice is that they're genetically identical. The mother who
was fed one diet rich in nutrients presumably was able to regulate gene
expression in a certain way that gave obese mice with yellow fur. The other
mother was fed a different diet which was alternatively effect the gene
expression and resulted in a brown furred, non obese mouse. So importantly,
these two mice are genetically identical, but they turned out appearance wise
very different. We refer to these as having the same genotype. But a slightly
different epigenome, and a very different appearance or phenotype.
>> So although this is yet to be shown in humans, it demonstrates that genes are
not our destiny. Their expression is influenced by what we do and get exposed
to from our environment. So let's go to this quiz.